this video is brought to you by
Squarespace whether it's your new
professional just a lifelong passion
style your journey to website Glory with
Squarespace check out their amazing
all-in-one platform through the link in
the description below more on them in a
bit
throughout history there has been one
episode used consistently to describe
the most powerful successful important
rulers of a kingdom or Empire the great
there was Ramesses II in Egypt Cyrus in
Persia Alexander in Greece Constantine
Rome Peter in Russia and so so many more
but not so many in England though as the
nation has proven to be quite stingy
when it comes to that particular moniker
it's got other badass nicknames like
Willy and the Conqueror or Richard the
lionheart and more than its fair share
of weird ones such as Ethel red the
unready or read with the Confessor but
not so many great in fact there is only
one English king who ever received this
appellation Alfred the Great you'll
notice me said English king are not King
of England which is why a win not
counting knut here but what did Alfred
do to be worthy of such a title that's
the question that we're going to attempt
to answer in today's video from bending
off the Viking Invasion to putting
England on the path of a single unified
Kingdom we look at the life in the rain
of Alfred the Great
foreign
Alfred was born in 849 A.D a Wantage in
Berkshire County this is where the Royal
Estate once stood he was the youngest of
six children to aetherworth King of
Wessex and his wife hospice Alfred was
born during a time of great turmoil and
changed for England for centuries ever
since the Romans left and the
Anglo-Saxons arrived in England the land
had been traditionally divided into
Seven Kingdoms they were northumbria
Mercier base danglia owessex Kent Sussex
and Essex this period of English History
was known as the heptarchy but it ended
in the 9th century thanks mainly to
Alfred's grandfather Egbert King of the
West Saxons who managed to bring Kent
Sussex and Essex under his domain thus
claiming sovereignty over all of
Southern England and transforming Wessex
into the most powerful Kingdom in the
land but that was not the biggest change
that England faced no there was
something else an external threat that
posed a much greater danger to the
worlds and ultimately it would have a
much more significant impact on British
history the Vikings had invaded England
Viking things hardly need an
introduction but let's give them a quick
one anyway they were seafaring Raiders
from Scandinavia who arrived on English
Shores during the late 8th Century the
Anglo-Saxon Chronicle one of the main
sources for this period of History it
aimed 787 A.D as the year when three
ships full of northmen sought the land
of the English Nation for the first time
the first thing they did was kill the
local official called a Reeve who set
out to meet them so it was clear from
the very beginning that these new
arrivals did not come with peaceful
intentions then a few years later in 793
A.D another landmark moment came when
the Vikings raided the monastery on
lindisfarne island also known simply as
holy Island because it was such an
important scent of Christianity raids
had occurred before but this one sent a
devastating Shockwave throughout the
Anglo-Saxon kingdoms and today is
regarded by many as the start of the
Viking age in England the Anglo-Saxons
knew that things just got real or the
more expressive way the chronicle put it
was on the sixth day before the Ides of
January in the same year the harrowing
inroads of heathen men made lamentable
havoc in the Church of God in holy
Island by raping and Slaughter during
the first few years of their Invasion
Viking forces consisted mainly of small
raiding parties that sailed the
waterways of a lasered blunder but they
soon discovered that the pillaging was
good the weather was warm and the
resistance was minimal so more and more
Vikings decided to stick around and
settle in England
[Music]
by the time Alfred was born the Vikings
had become a serious problem for most of
the Anglo-Saxon kingdoms but not so much
for Wessex which had the strength to
repel any Invasion attempts during
Alfred's childhood years his father and
his older brothers fought several
battles against the Vikings generally
with positive results in 851 A.D
Alfred's father King ather Wolfe
defeated the Invaders of the battle of
aklia which was described in the
chronicle as the greatest Slaughter of
the Heathen Army that we have ever heard
reported that same year Alfred Zelda's
sibling and king of Kent aethol
stanfordo by complete in a sandwich even
though he won the day ethelston
completely disappeared from historical
records from then on so presumably we're
gonna say was killed in the battle but
even with Ethel stand dead Alfred still
had three older brothers ahead of him in
the queue for kingship so his Prospect
of ever taking the throne we're not
looking too promising in 853 his father
sent Young Alfred to Rome entrusting him
to the care of Pope Leo IV then two
years later Leo passed away as did
Aether Wolf's wife this prompted the
Aging King to make a pilgrimage to Rome
which was something that he had wanted
to do for a long time but it kept
putting off he picked up Alfred on his
way back to Wessex and just to make the
return trip a bit more interesting he
stopped by the court of Charles the bald
King of the Franks and married his 12
year old daughter Judith of Flanders now
if he thought the new trophy wife would
make things awkward back home well you
do not know the half of it while Acer
wolf was gone he left his oldest son
athebold in charge of the Kingdom as it
turned out aetherborne liked being King
so when his father returned the
following year he didn't feel like
seeding power back to him as you might
imagine this made for a rather tense
family reunion ethelwald had the support
of some powerful officials as well so
for a time there was distinct
possibility of Civil War breaking out in
Wessex ultimately though cooler heads
prevailed baby Ethel feared that he
would lose the war with his son maybe he
feared that internal strife would serve
Wessex up to the Vikings who were
greedily sharpening their axes maybe he
just thought that he was getting too old
for this but he reached a compromise and
divided his kingdom into two parts one
for him one for his son compromise was
effective at preventing a civil war but
it didn't matter for very long because
Aether wolf died just two years later in
858. in his world he tried to divide
everything as equitably as possible in
order to prevent any power struggles
between his sons he gave his kingdom to
his two oldest Sons the aforementioned
aetherwald and Ethel Bert although we're
not quite sure who ruled over what again
it didn't really matter for long because
just two and a half years later a
thorbald also kicked the bucket and at
that point a Thor bird came to rule over
the whole shebang one final interesting
tidbit about aetherwald remember Judith
Flanders his father's 12 year old bride
well after Aether wolf died she got
remarried to Ethel bald which would make
her Alfred stepmother and also his
sister-in-law ethelbert served as king
of versiggs for five whole years
doubling his older brother's high score
the kingship went to the next sibling
waiting in line ethyl read not to be
confused with a threat the unready who
came a bit later he did one better than
Ethan reigning for six years before
dying in 871 A.D just like that with all
of his siblings dropping like flies it
was now time for Alfred to take the
throne and to be honest he could not
have picked a worse time for it because
his kingdom was now under serious threat
from the most brutal and destructive
force to ever come to his lands the
great Heathen Army all right we'll get
back to today's video in just a segment
first here's a word from today's
excellent sponsor Squarespace looked two
civil things maybe you've got an idea
for a website or a business YouTube
channel podcast something like that
knocking around in your mind's world too
the only way to figure out whether that
is worth doing is to get it out there
into the world and that can be daunting
because you know it's scary to try new
things but not knowing how to set up a
website is not an excuse there are no
excuses available with Squarespace
Squarespace allows you to create a
powerful website for whatever you're up
to you want to sell something online
yeah easy to set up a store with
Squarespace podcast starting a YouTube
channel while you're on a website to
compliment it it all starts on
Squarespace with a beautiful template
that you can customize to your heart's
contents or you start from scratch or
you can easily move over from an
existing domain making everything super
easy to manage don't start from scratch
though just use a template like I say no
excuses and once you've gone through the
super easy customization process there
are no updates no patches no tank BS to
deal with and Squarespace also handles
all of that websitey stuff podcasts yes
mailing lists of course social
Integrations and so much more like I say
Squarespace removes the excuses to your
dreams just go get started now go to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com biographics to save 10
of your first purchase of a website or a
domain and now let's get back into it
in 865 A.D the same year Aether red
became king of Wessex a great Viking
Force invaded England it was known as
the great Heathen Army after how it was
described in the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle
and it became clear that this time the
Vikings were not interested in simply
plundering a few monasteries filling
their coffers with gold and silver and
spending the winter in England before
returning back home this time the
Vikings were here to stay as we allow
ourselves to indulge a little and treat
the north sagas as historical facts then
we can say that the Army was chiefly led
by the sons of legendary Viking Ragnar
last Brock who was supposedly killed by
King Ayler of northumbria by being cast
into a pit of venomous snakes therefore
it was up to his offspring halfton or
agneson Ube and Iber the Boneless to
Avenger's death that is ostensibly the
reason for the assault although many
would argue that given how successful
the Vikings had been in the decades they
first arrived in England it was only a
matter of time before they launched a
full-scale Invasion the one thing that
was clear was that none of the
Anglo-Saxon kingdoms were prepared for
such a force and started falling One By
One The Vikings first arrived in East
Anglia but the king bribed them with
gold and Provisions to leave his kingdom
alone instead they traveled into
northumbria where they captured the city
of York and installed a puppet leader as
the new king before moving on to Murcia
where they captured the city of
Nottingham Mercy room Wessex were allies
so King Ethel red LED an Army in 868 to
try and take back Nottingham his brother
Alfred also joined The Fray making this
the first time that he fought the
Vikings although there were mixed
results the siege of Nottingham was
inconclusive so ultimately the Norsemen
were paid off and they left again
returning to East Anglia oh where they
slew King Edward the Martyr and replaced
him with another pup King obviously it
was only a matter of time before the
Danes would Target Wessex and that time
came in 870 A.D the West Saxon started
off on the right foot with the victory
at the Battle of englefield however the
good times didn't last long because just
four days later Aether red and Alfred
are Allied their army and attacked the
main Viking encampment at reading hoping
to strike a decisive blow to the enemy
unfortun actually that was not what
happened as Alfred's Chief chronicler
Assa relates to us four days afterward
King atherod and his brother Alfred
uniting their forces and assembling an
army marched reading where on their
arrival at the castle gate they cut to
pieces and overthrew the Heathen whom
they found outside the fortifications
but the Heathen fought no less valiantly
and a rushing-like wolves out of every
gate waged battle with all of their
might both sides fought long and
fiercely let it last sad to say the
Christians turned their backs the
heathens obtained the Victory and hailed
the battlefield the West action defeat
was followed by a big victory at the
Battle of Ashdown and then by another
loss at Merton soon after that it was
becoming clear that while the great
Heathen Army was formidable the Kingdom
of Wessex was no pushover the two sides
were evenly matched so determining a
Victor would be no easy feat it wouldn't
be atherode's problem anymore though
because he died shortly after the loss
at Merton leaving Alfred to take up the
mantle of King and deal with the Viking
Invasion knocking at his door and deal
with it he did the best way he knew how
paid them off not very heroic sure but
realistically it was the only way to
save his newly gained Kingdom right
after he became king Alfred's forces
suffered a few more losses including a
bad one at Wilton and so he had no
choice but to make peace with them and
let Mercia deal with the problem of
course Alfred knew that this was merely
a stalling tactic the Vikings oh were
startled but they would soon be back and
it's in greater numbers but he hoped
that by then he'll be ready for them
[Music]
wessex's loss was Mercy as gain and by
gain we'd mean that they gained a whole
lot of angry Norsemen who stormed into
London to spend the winter there now it
was mercier's turn to play past the
Vikings so they paid them off as well
and the great Heathen Army traveled up
north to northumbria where the people
had rebelled against their puppet King
Alfred's tactic brought him a few years
of Peace as the Norse Invaders were busy
ravaging the other kingdoms but another
war was always inevitable and as if his
enemy wasn't strong enough already the
Vikings received reinforcements from
Scandinavia known as the summer Army but
this actually worked in Alfred's favor
because the Danes were so certain of
their success that they divided their
army into two parts half of it went
towards Wessex while the other half was
led by a half Dan who took it into
Scotland and Ireland by that point there
had been a few changes in the leadership
of the great even Army two of the
original leaders either the Boneless and
bag sag had both been killed in battle
during the previous years and half Dan
himself would die in Ireland a short
while later the army that traveled south
was led by a man named guthrum who would
go on to have a very close connection to
Alfred anyway the renewed fighting
kicked off in 876 A.D when the Danes
stormed the town of Wareham which was
taken by surprise and offered Little
Resistance unfortunately for Alfred
warum was pretty heavily fortified he
wasn't too keen on the idea of laying
Siege to his own town so begrudgingly he
paid them off again in order to make
peace once the Viking Army had left
where amid took them about five seconds
to double cross the West Saxons and
attack another fortified town this time
Exeter intending to spend the winter
Within safety of its walls now however
Alfred gained the advantage because the
fleet that would have reinforced the
Heathen Army encountered a great storm
off the coast of Dorset and over 120
long ships were wrecked against the
cliffs an open battle might have gone in
his favor but like before the Norsemen
preferred to stay inside Exeter
surrounded by hostages they held a
pretty good bargaining chip so the
West's action King made peace with them
once more once spring arrived the
Vikings departed Exeter this time
actually leaving Wessex and heading into
Mercier but they would not wait another
five years before attacking Wessex again
it had become clear that Alfred's
kingdom was the last piece of the puzzle
for them the only realm they had not yet
managed to subjugate sure they raided it
a few times and got paid a pretty penny
for it but combat wise the two sides
were like Rocky and Apollo pretty evenly
matched however gothram was determined
to settle the matter once and for all in
January 878 he led a surprise attack on
Chippenham in Wiltshire County using it
as a base of operations to launch
massive raids throughout Wessex some
claim that Alfred himself had been at
the Royal Estate at Chippenham over
Christmas which was why the Vikings
chose it as their target but that he
managed to escape just in time with a
small retinue of bodyguards and Retreat
to Somerset there Alfred settled at
athel knee which became his stronghold
as he coordinated with local militias to
raise an army and strike back at the
Invaders Alva decided to Fight Fire with
Fire and used the Danes as Guerrilla
tactics against them also he burned some
cakes in case you have no idea what
we're talking about there there's an old
popular legend about Alfred taking
shelter inside the home of a peasant
woman who did not recognize him and just
assumed that he was another Saxon
Soldier she let him rest and went
outside to collect more firewood warning
him to keep watch over some cakes that
were baking in the fart after it however
had more pressing issues on his mind and
he did not notice when the cake started
to burn the woman returned home to the
smell of charred bread and gave Alfred a
proper scolding for being so negligent
and forgetful not realizing that she was
shouting at her King but Alfred was
humble and forgiving so he simply
apologized the woman thanked of her
kindness and went on his way after all
he had a bit of an invasion to fight
after seven weeks of skirmishes Alfred
had assembled an army about 3 000 men
from wheelchair Somerset and ham chip
and was ready to clash with guthrum and
his Vikings the battle occurred at
Eddington in May 878 and it was a
resounding victory for Alfred forcing
the Danes to retreat back to Chippenham
Assa the chronicler gives us more
details the next morning at dawn he
moved his standards to Eddington and
therefore bravely and perseveringly by
means of a close Shield wall against the
whole Army of the Heathen whom at length
with Divine help he defeated with great
Slaughter and pursued them flying to
their stronghold immediately he slew all
the men and carried off all the horses
and cattle that he could not find
without the Fortress and thereupon
pitched his camp with all his army
before the gates of the Heathen
stronghold as you can see Alfred showed
no mercy to the injured and captured and
removed all the animals Out Of Reach of
the Norsemen intending to starve them
out of their Fortress after 14 days the
cold and hungry Danes were ready to
accept Alfred's terms the King of the
West Saxons had won the day
[Music]
the Battle of Eddington was unlike any
other defeat that the Vikings had
suffered in England and it came at a
pivotal point in its history northumbria
East Anglia and Murcia had already
fallen to the Invaders if guthrum had
won here chances or a good that Wessex
would have followed giving the Invaders
the complete set but Alfred realized
that one victory was not enough to
completely Drive The Vikings out of
England instead he came up with some
realistic terms for peace at the Treaty
of wedmore the Vikings had to leave
Wessex obviously and guthrum had to be
baptized as a Christian probably the
truly surprising part was that the
Vikings actually kept their word this
time not only did they head back to
Mercia but three weeks later guthrum and
30 of his closest men descended upon the
village of Allah to receive their
baptisms guthrum was lowered into the
holy font by Alfred himself and then
adopted the Christian name of ethelston
afterwards Gotham ruled as king of East
Anglia for over a decade maintaining a
relatively cordial relationship with
Alfred a few years later the two of them
formalized an official treaty known
simply as the Treaty of Alfred and
girlfriend room which encourage trade
between their two sides and also agreed
upon equal punishments should ordain
killer Saxon or vice versa but most
importantly the treaty established the
boundaries of their two kingdoms which
were recognized by both Kings they were
described as running up the Thames and
then up the lair and along the lair to
its source and then in a straight line
to Bedford and then up the house to
Watling Street basically each kingdom
got half of Mercia with London staying
on the Wessex side and the north side
becoming known as Dain law the new
treaty brought Alfred and his Kingdom's
much-needed peace although they didn't
become immune from raids which continued
all throughout the rest of his Reign
fortunately for them most were only
minor skirmishes it seemed that the bulk
of the Viking Army is still looking for
a good brawl had enough of the English
weather and across the channel to the
continent to fight with Franks this gave
Alfred the time he needed to reorganize
his army and his defenses trying to make
his kingdom as Viking proof as possible
he developed a strong Navy to counter
the dreaded Viking longships he
introduced a new tax and conscription
system which maintained a standing army
on a rotation basis so that he could
raise a rapid reaction force in the
event of a rage without having to take
their peasants away from their crops
most importantly Alfred went on a
building spree of fortified settlements
called Burrs positioned strategically
throughout the Kingdom so that no part
of Wessex was more than 20 miles away
from such a refuge Alfred kept busy
outside of his scuffles with the Danes
as well he realized that after More Than
A Century of Vikings plundering and
burning most monasteries that they ran
across the number of people in his
kingdom who still spoke Latin was about
the same as those who spoke Klingon
therefore he enacted A kingdom-wide
literacy program by translating books on
history geography philosophy and
religion from Latin to Old English and
distributing them to all the Bishops in
wessigs who Could disseminate them among
their congregations he also commissioned
the writing of the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle
of idol document on the history of
England which we have already used
extensively in this video during the
890s the Viking attacks picked up pace
again but thanks to Alfred's military
reforms they did not post is a serious
threat to Wessex by that point Alfred
starred himself as king of the English
instead of King of the West Saxons it
was clear that his ultimate goal was to
unite all of England a lofty ambition
that Alfred would not live to see
fulfilled he died on October 26 899 A.D
aged 51 and although he did not unify
England he set the wheels in motion and
allowed his son and Grandson to finish
his work the kingdom of England would
emerge less than three decades later in
a story that will probably continue
another time